- Can you please tell the camera
the Stationary Astronauts got me?
- Yo, Stationary Astronauts
fucking figured it out.
I don't know how with the
fucking haircut and everything
but he fucking did, he did it.
(laughing)
- Yo, dick! (laughs)
(electronic music)
Okay Gary, we're good to go baby.
We're good to go.
You got a mic right there.
- I got a mic, awesome.
- Mr. Vanderchuck.
- Yes, sir.
- I am so appreciative.
Dude, I signed the
dotted line with nothing.
- Yes.
- And through grit and will--
What was the big first domino that fell?
- The big first domino was Zack Nadler
getting back to me a day early.
- Interesting.
- Yeah, so everyone
was on Christmas break.
I got the automated email back saying that
they were gonna get back
to me on January 3rd.
He got back to me on January 2nd
and I had already hit him with,
because we have a cool
thing going on here.
We double in population on a monthly basis
due to visitors alone
and he likes the story
and I don't know if any of this
was getting relayed to you.
- No.
- But then it just came down to
man, my pitch game was
on point and I really--
- Yeah, 'cause he's a tough filter
because we've got a
thousand people a month
that don't have the economics
that are like pitch it,
we don't like we don't
lock up dates like that.
And you also had to give
a deposit at some point.
- Bro, the deposit was the toughest part.
- Had to be.
- So like he actually
dropped it in half for me.
- Good, man, Zach big
shout out to you Nadler.
- Straight-up.
- Like wow.
- Wow like he, honestly
Nadler made it happen
because he must have
really believed in you.
- He did.
And it was just so crazy
because I knew I was irking him.
I knew I was pissing him off.
He's New York state of
mind, no games dawg.
- 100%.
- Unfortunately like money
doesn't grow on trees
here in the Midwest, you
know what I'm saying?
- So what was the first domino after that?
- It was Kathleen Harrington,
the President of the Chamber
of Commerce believed in me.
- Love it.
- And I got to sit down dude
out of fate, I got to sit down
and she just like cut me an initial check
and it was nothing big.
It was just a $5,000 check.
- That's big though.
- But it got my social--
- It gave you leverage.
- Yeah bro, it gave me leverage
and then my boy Marcus Sherels
who's our punt returner
for the Minnesota Vikings, he's like
you know what man?
I got you dawg, I got you.
And he cut me that deposit
check on blind faith.
- Wow, good.
- But he was my point guard.
We graduated together.
You just met his brother and sister-in-law
in the meet and greet and
that was the first domino dawg
because then that got Nadler off my back
but this is the crazy thing is
after I turned over the first
deposit, it was only 25%.
So we did it on blind faith.
Immediately DJ is hitting me up like yo,
you got the rest of that deposit?
I like oh shit dawg!
And they just kept giving
me more time, more time.
- Wow.
- Because they believed in it.
- I didn't know any of this stuff.
I told Nadler, nobody
only take 50% deposits
and don't fuck around on impact.
I don't need you closing
my schedule for a day
and then coming back and being
like it's not gonna happen.
- Yeah.
- Well listen he clearly
saw something in you
and he was right.
- I'm telling you Gary.
- Pretty eyes and a fucked up haircut.
- Yeah, dude.
I'm telling you no, I gotta
get rid of this thing dawg.
- No dude, it's awesome, I'm joking.
I wish I had that hair, go ahead.
Right Caleb?
- No but okay, so we were just moving
and then the hustle just kept going
and as the momentum started picking up
these powers-that-be these,
these heads started believing in me
'cause they started catch a wind like
I don't know who Gary is
but this motherfucker Nik's
got some energy to him.
And he's really hustling
like I sacrificed my job of Reebok,
like all my other jobs dawg.
I had a baby throughout this process.
- Jesus.
I have a four month old daughter.
- Congrats.
- Like dawg like my
hustle is on A1 right now.
- I get it.
- You know and like--
- And now it's real and it's here.
- Yes.
- Is it emotional for it to be real?
- It is because--
- When it's in your head
and just an imagination
to like actually see it
in real life is crazy.
- Yeah.
And once I met you I was like oh shit,
this is my guy right here.
He's just real, you know?
But the thing is I--
- Yeah, was that a worry a little bit?
- It was, it was.
- Right, like you spend all this time
and all this capital like what if I was...
but you kind of warned him
that I was cool, right?
(man speaking off mic)
Yeah, so you were a little bit more calm
because of that, right?
- Yes, yes.
- That makes sense.
- But I gambled, I'm taking a loss
but at the same time
dude, it's a fucking win.
- The next event, the next, pfft.
The next event you're set.
- Yeah, bro.
- You're gonna be able to
leverage this in perpetuity.
You're gonna take a million screenshots
of me wearing this T-shirt
and I mean, you've won.
- Yeah and that's kind of
what we're trying to do Gary
is like just use this to propel us
because we're already working on
our second installment next year.
- Makes a ton of sense.
And by the way whoever your big dawg is,
if she or he wants to
talk to me on the phone
of who you guys are,
I'm thrilled to do it.
- Thank you brother.
- You're welcome.
- That's the fucking ultimate
endorsement right there.
- 100%.
- Thank you so much.
- One minute 'cause my times fucked up
but we'll be like yo, Tim
Ferriss mother fucker do it.
- Yeah absolutely dude, I love Tim dude.
Four hour workweek, shout it out.
So then the the ball was just rolling
and then as these powers-that-be
started riding with us it
just started gaining steam
but the thing is this is kind of
what we want you to
talk about on stage too.
Like money is good here
but consumerism's fucked.
They started handing--
- When we go onstage,
I know we're doing this in a podcast
but I want to ask you.
There's 40 minutes of me,
I'm up there for how long?
- You're up there for another
35 minutes after that.
- In what format, Q&A?
- 20 minute Q&A and then
we're gonna present you
with the worthy warrior award.
- Why don't we do 35, 40
or like we'll figure it out
but I think you should come on and ask me
the first two or three questions
before we would open up
because I want to be honest with you
like 'cause I want this
to be great for you.
I'm gonna black out up there.
So you're gonna be like
yo, like shit on everybody
and get them fucking focused on something
and I'm gonna like say one
thing and go down a path
and be like how the...
Basically here's how it works.
People are like Gary, go out
there and say yellow banana.
I'm not cool and I go out there
and basically talk about chocolate
kangaroos the whole time.
And they're like yo, what happened?
I'm like yo, I told you.
So I'm gonna go out there and
try to bring the most value
but I think you can definitely come in
and be like hey let's bring
this down to earth about us
and ask three questions
and then I'll give answers
and I think you'll get what you need.
Does that make sense?
- As we go on?
- After we, after I think
when I stop my keynote
I'm gonna transition to
Q&A, you should come out
and like do the first
two or three questions.
- Gotcha brother, got you.
- Fair?
- Absolutely.
- I think it'd be a good
look for you, got it?
And then this way 'cause I'm gonna talk
macro to bring value.
And then you come in and be like yo,
why don't you bring this down to earth?
I got a couple questions about,
you see where I'm going?
- Absolutely, that's a good look.
- Good.
- Now, to talk about kind of
what drove me to bring you here.
- Yes.
- It was really I grew up
slanging baseball cards
or basketball cards was my repertoire
and I was you know--
- Garnett's and Maris?
- I was obsessed with Garnett and Mari,
Kobe Bryant rookie cards.
You know what I'm saying?
I was obsessed with Shaquille O'Neal
and then it turned into learning
the power of trade value.
And then I was also
slanging in newspapers,
shout out the newspapers.
Back when print was hot, back in the '90s.
- [Man] It's coming back in a big way.
- He used to work for Post-Bulletin.
- Give me that metal thing.
I've got to drill some metal in my back.
This is my new thing, keep going.
- I had a boy dude.
- I'm like fixing my back.
- Rolling the fuck out
of himself right now.
So then it was just like
you bro, early 2000s hit
and I grew up in a family
of small business owners
but it was like I was
never handed anything.
It's like no motherfucker
you're coming to wash dishes
and bus tables for $50 a
night just for shits and gigs.
And then I would just
turn that into a hustle.
So like I started...
once I started working on my own
every winter say I'd get laid off
because we get harsh winters here.
I'm slanging sewing
purses for hippie chicks.
One for 50, two for 80,
they get to pick out the fabric and beads.
And it was just like the steady grind
and I never knew who Gary Vaynerchuk was
and then once I started learning about you
probably a year and a
half, two years ago--
- And how did that happen? Instagram?
- It was Internet scrolling.
Scrolling on some timeline
and it was like this mother
fucker is speaking my language
and it's the language,
it's beyond your New York state of mind.
It's like he's on my wavelength
or I'm on his wavelength
and I'm definitely obviously
a decade behind him
but at the same time--
- Are you 32?
- I'm 30.
- 30, amazing.
- So I'm behind him but at
the same time I was like--
- When did you turn 30?
- February third.
- So did you feel
anything turning 30 or no?
- I actually it was...
yeah of course I did, of course I did
but I got a baby on the way
so it's like I'm growing up regardless.
You know what I'm saying?
I got married last year and
I'm growing up regardless
and I knew when I was 30 I
better have my purpose dialed in.
That's what I was worried about is
I gotta have my purpose dialed in
and my purpose in this
life is connecting people.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah, you've got good people skills.
- Having conversations
and it all comes from
just the confidence.
People ask me dude how did
you get Gary Vaynerchuk?
Confidence, that's all it was.
- You decided and then
you worked backwards.
Listen, you need things
to work out sometimes.
You know like Nadler for whatever reason
was cool with giving you
like a discount on deposits,
which is something
that's like pretty hard,
like I trust him so he can
do whatever the fuck he wants
but he knows like we don't do it.
And then like Kathleen, was that her name?
- Yeah, Kathleen Harrington
- She gave you the shot.
She could've said no.
I believe in that shit,
if you if you understand
what you're trying to do,
it gives you a North Star and
then you try to figure it out.
I don't know what else to say.
Like it's just a lot better
and money can't be the North Star.
It just can't.
- Every single day when I'm going on live
I'm talking about how lucky I am,
how lucky we are to just be
in the position we're in.
Was there ever a point
Gary where you look back
and it was like man I'm so
lucky to have the mom I had,
the dad I had or the the setup I had
where I got to help
build my dad's business.
- I think...
I think like in that way
like literally doing that
probably, probably...
42, probably seven, eight, nine years ago.
But I lived my life as if my whole life.
I always lived grateful.
I just never thought of it that way.
I always lived thankful,
grateful, appreciative,
lack of entitlement my whole life
but I didn't think about it.
I wasn't psychoanalyzing myself.
When people started paying attention to me
after I wrote some books
and gave some speeches,
it made me ask why?
Like why was that good on stage?
Why do people like me?
Like why was this happening?
Why do people hate me?
Why did people not like me right away?
Like why were these things happening.
And that's when I stumbled
probably seven to 10 years ago,
I'm like ooh, boy am I
grateful for my circumstance.
You know you start understanding.
You know a lot of people
talk about white privilege
or American privilege, male privilege.
I think it's a mental-health game.
I'm just privileged to
have my together mentally.
Like self-esteem,
self-awareness, gratitude,
these things really added
up to a good concoction
that has really worked for me.
- [Nik] That train of thought is a gift.
There are so many people...
that way of thought is a gift.
There are so many people who
will go their entire life
and not even know what
the hell empathy is.
- 100%, you know not even know the word.
- [Nik] Yes.
- That's one of the biggest
reasons I'm pushing it so hard.
Just by even people acknowledging
the word empathy or gratitude.
Dudes that we're trying to kill it,
didn't use words like empathy
and gratitude seven years ago.
Just like seeing like
sleeved up like rad dudes
roll up to me like yo, kindness dawg.
I'm like... (laughs)
It's just so...
Honestly I genuinely
believe my great legacy
potentially may be that I made
emotionally intelligent soft skills alpha.
You'll never believe this,
this is a super interesting to me.
The fact that pink was a boys color
and blue was a girl's
color back in the day
is kind of how I think about
gratitude, empathy kindness.
I'm like I'm gonna trick
these young fucking dawgs
into like thinking this shit is cool
and then one day in 50 years,
people are gonna be like
the alpha male traits
are like gratitude and kindness
and if I could pull that off
then it's like (imitates explosion sound)
then you can like...
I think a lot about my legacy
and I actually think that is probably
the best bet I have right now.
I can penetrate young alpha males.
Most people that can
penetrate young alpha males
talk about cliche young alpha male shit
and it's very like bang chicks, like win,
like that stuff.
And I can get...
I don't know honestly,
it's a very interesting thing to watch
even for me to watch it
outside of my own self.
I'm like am I really
making gratitude cool?
It's an incredible
feeling right now for me.
It's a combination of honing my skills,
understanding Instagram
and YouTube at its apex,
believing in it.
You know I think one thing I
always was was very sensitive.
I cried a lot as a kid.
I always stood up for
kids that got bullied
to my detriment in popularity.
I'm very emotional.
I had this like big date
in high school to Lion King
and cried when the dad died
right in front of the girl
like I've got that in me and
like never really gave a fuck
and it's really working out.
Like it's really fun for my high school
and junior high friends,
grammar school even to
that degree friends.
Like give me daps.
It's been really interesting.
It's been really interesting to see them
come out of the wood
works and like defend me.
Even like people I didn't know super well,
just like jump in and be like no, dude.
Like don't be a dick, like
I knew him in junior high
and he fucking like was nice.
You know it's just, (laughs)
it's been really very
cool to watch actually.
- Do you believe in the zodiac calendar?
- I don't.
Now I'll tell you this.
Maybe, I just actually don't know.
Are we talking like Scorpio?
- [Nik] Yeah.
- So like I'm a Scorpio
and I feel like I've got Scorpio...
First of all I don't know
what Scorpio things are
but like the whole stinging
and like I don't know.
like probably there's got
to be some fun truth to it.
I'm just not educated enough
to know if I do or I don't
and I don't gravitate
towards figuring it out.
- Okay so as we enter the Aquarian age,
that's feminine energy
and what you have done
with the female brand
as well as how you're pushing empathy,
you're pushing feminine
energy on the planet right now
and it'S really positive.
- You know it's funny, I used to say that
and now I'm asking myself is empathy
and all these things actually feminine
or did we kind of position them that way?
And I feel like that's where I've landed,
which is they're neutral
energies in my mind,
though I might be wrong 'cause
I'm not educated on this.
It's not what I really look
at but I will say this.
Something's definitely happening.
For real and it's fucking amazing.
And it makes me feel incredible
and if God forbid I even pull off 10% of
what I think I could pull off,
I'm making so much positive
impact in the world.
A woman up here said that
she was laid off from QVC.
Did you capture it?
Did you see the woman?
- [Man] I was there, I got it.
- You got it?
You saw where I got caught a little bit?
- [Man] She went woo.
- Yeah, good can you give it to me?
'Cause it's a real nice moment.
She was like look, I got laid off
and I was like sitting
on my couch depressed
for two three months and that fuck Monday,
like fuck, like make Monday your bitch.
She was like that changed my life.
She just got like and that's crazy.
Like I don't know what else to say like...
I don't need anybody ever on earth again
to say anything nice, just that
woman today here in Russia.
Here, that minute, worth
the whole fucking time.
You're changing somebody's life.
So anyway, I'm feeling great
about things right now.
I really am and I'm and I
feel like I'm just starting.
- I call you, I've been telling everybody
Gary Vaynerchuk is the no--
- It really feels like,
I know you put the D in
there I know, all the time.
- No, Gary Vaynerchuk is
the Nostradamus of trends.
- Do you feel that way?
- I don't because I think
Nostradamus, first of all,
I actually want to be Nostradamus
because he did really cool shit.
Like if I was Nostradamus
here's what I would say.
In 2097 the red-headed will do the thing
and then what we do in 2097 is like oh,
the mountain exploded, it's a volcano.
That's what he meant by redhead.
Like so he was so general that we like...
now some of the shit is not...
you know what's funny?
I got super freaking into Nostradamus
in fifth and sixth grade.
Like I didn't care about school at all
but one day like on a rainy day,
they like brought in the
fucking TV with the VHS
and they played Nostradamus.
And I was like who the, what the fuck?
This is amazing.
I got really into it.
I don't think I'm that.
Here's what I do think I am.
So the reason I interrupt people
so much when I interview on my podcast is
'cause my brain goes too fast.
Like I know what's happening.
I have a sixth sense, like I
know what you're about to say
or you say one word and I
already know your sentence
so I'm like let's get to the next ship
but the audience is like yo fuck face,
what was he gonna say?
So what I think I'm very good at is
seeing trends very quickly
and acting on them.
They've happened but for some
reason nobody's seeing it
and I am and I'm acting
on and speaking to it
and so it feels like it.
I just think that I'm
able to decipher big data
and social things a little
bit quicker than most.
- , so you run Joe Rogan's podcast?
- [Gary] I was.
- You were interrupting
the shit out of it.
- [Gary] Was I?
- You were and I was---
- [Gary] And that was his show.
- Yeah and I was like damn
what's up with Gar bear?
This dude is just interrupting
the king of conversation.
And then I look back I'm like damn dude,
Gary was on to something.
Now do you still have a relationship
with some of the top
podcasters in Los Angeles
and do you ever try to make
your way back on the circuit
or you're just too busy?
- I'm too busy like Joe I
really wanted to do that show.
He's got the best show.
He's killing it.
We DM each other once
in a while some love.
What was I, what did you
say that I was on to?
- Well I just knew that this guy
knows he is so confident
because this is actually
probably the first six months
I even knew who the hell Gary Vee was.
- So it was cool that I was right about
McGregor and Mayweather?
- Well that was cool as shit because you--
- Like that'll be fun
like nine years from now
when somebody listens to
it and be like oh shit.
It's fun now but...
- You're just so tapped in
and there's a difference
between being right
and being narcissistic.
You know, I'm sure you--
- I only talk about shit I know.
Like if you're really gay
you want to talk about this
apricot you're eating right now
or a peach or whatever
the fuck I'm eating?
I'd be like sure and you
be like talk about it.
I'd be like it's delicious.
You're like you know the
pit comes from the apple?
you would just hear me quiet
because I have nothing else to say.
I think the thing that
is happening with me is
I'm talking about and I'm
being interviewed by people
talking about the shit that I know,
that I'm gonna be on tilt.
But if you want to talk
about poker right now,
you'd be stunned how quiet I be.
I don't know how to play it.
I mean I know how to play it
but not like all you fuckers
that grew up on the Internet
and really know how to play.
You know like I am actually...
where I think I'm my most fun to watch
because it's not my normal
self is couples dinners
where I want to be socially like
a good partner-in-crime
to the six couples.
So I'll on purpose if Caleb
and a significant other
and my wife and I went out,
I'd be like, talk to
the significant other,
be like what do you do?
And she's a lawyer, he's
a lawyer, I don't know.
Like you know, that I'll
listen for 30 minutes.
And I think that yeah.
I mean I think on Rogan
or anything else if I know
what I'm talking about
like I was cutting him
off 'cause he was wrong.
He said the McGregor and
Mayweather fight wouldn't happen.
I said it would and so I get excited.
I was right.
- Where were you at when you
definitely bought that fight?
- Yeah, I bought that fight.
I was in the Hamptons
'cause it was summer, right?
- [Nik] Yeah.
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Yeah, August last year.
- You were in the Hamptons?
- Eight or nine guys, I was
at my home and it was fun.
Actually his first three, four
rounds got us a little going.
It was a lot of fun.
I was very neutral, which was weird.
I'm not usually neutral.
It makes sense those two
fuckers made me neutral.
Like I was kind of like whatever.
I was like in a lot of ways like love/hate
with both of them.
I don't really know either one of them.
But I have a lot of empathy
and like curiosities around both of them
'cause we're unique dudes.
And so it was fun to watch.
- Personality-wise would
you consider yourself
the Mayweather/McGregor of business?
- Yeah, I mean I can't
kind of get away from that.
- Gary, you're McGregor of business dawg.
You're just McGregor has branded himself
and catapulted himself to
the likes we've never seen.
- Here's the thing.
I think I'm more Drake and I'll
explain what I mean by that.
Drake is self-deprecating
and deploys humility.
- [Man] His new album?
- Yeah.
So I think I'm a little more Drakey
though you know I haven't looked enough.
Mayweather doesn't do
humility or self deprecation
so I definitely know that.
McGregor seems to have that in him.
I just have a, right?
A little bit, a little bit.
So I think that makes the most sense
but I think I'm much more Drake.
Like I'm...
I'm really comfortable in my shortcomings
and I like them and I
like talking about them
because I think I'm the
greatest of all time
and I think I mean nothing
and I think that's balance.
Extreme balance which is why
I think I'm gonna have extreme results.
I really think I can be
the most heralded entrepreneur
of this generation.
I do not think I'll make more money
or even kind of business
impact than Zucks or Bezos
or Elon Musk or many others but I think
I'm gonna touch the most
entrepreneurs emotionally.
Create the most entrepreneurs,
help the most entrepreneurs,
help the most people
not do entrepreneurship,
and I think that's gonna be a big legacy.
- It makes sense when Drake's
new album's named Scorpion.
- Yeah, is he a Scorpio?
- I don't know.
No, he's an October baby, right?
- [Man] But he did the humility
and called out what everyone
was already saying about him
when he dropped the album.
I already know what everyone's saying.
- That's kind of like--
- Eight Mile.
- Eminem, Eight mile.
- 100%
- Right there.
- Me too, like I always do that.
You know what's funny?
I don't put myself in
a lot of risky spots.
The sneaker was fun because
I put myself in a risky spot.
Like that could have
been a real fucking flop.
Like when I was thinking
about that was like...
I remember one flight I was just like...
Dude, you're wearing a Scorpio
hat, that's kind of cool.
it's like the whole...
- [Nik] Full circle type shit.
The universe is talking to us.
- I remember one flight and that was fun,
I was like okay this could get ugly.
Like they may not sell any.
They may be like in the
dollar store closed out.
Like this could be stupid.
I felt confident but I knew
I was going into it that
that was a leap.
That that was like huh?
And that made that exciting
but it felt so natural, right,
to me so I felt confident.
Yeah.
- [Nik] Have you ever just
had a fateful instance
where you're like damn,
something higher than myself
is talking to me right now?
- I kind of feel like never and always.
- [Nik] Mm-hmm.
- You know?
- [Nik] Almost like just flowing out?
- I could feel like there's...
like look, here's what I would say.
I take no...
I am the byproduct of my
parents and my environment.
So I don't think of myself,
excuse me I'm about the sneeze.
And this is a really good sneeze,
if you're Russian you know
why I just got excited.
In the Russian superstition
when you sneeze
when you're saying something
it means that it's very true.
So it's really interesting to me
that I was just about to say
I don't get high on my own supply.
I don't think I'm special
not because I don't think I'm special,
like I know I'm having special results.
I just think that's the
cosine to my parents
and America and adversity, not me.
Vaynermedia, I get excited about.
I mean, I did that.
My kids one day I'll be like yo.
But like me?
That's my parents and
the year I grew up in
and like coming from
nothing and circumstance
and so like when people are like you're...
when people are like you're
Jesus, like you walk on water.
I'm like cool.
Thank you, oh my god but like cool.
When people like you're a charlatan,
you're full of shit,
you're snake oil sales man,
I'm like cool.
Like it's all quiet in my head.
It's super quiet in my head.
- [Nik] As promoters of Gary Vaynerchuk
and disciples of Gary Vaynerchuk
so often throughout this
process Gary I heard
I'm not gonna come to that.
I can go on YouTube and already hear.
and I know you talk about this.
Don't watch my shit,
you don't need to if
you're already doing it
but when people should
come see live entertainment
when it comes to dude, you
gotta grab Tony Robbins live.
That's when you get the goods.
Whether he's saying the same or not.
What do you say to people like that?
- I think that's a personal thing.
Like I have a lot of empathy of like
how you're thinking about event marketing
and things of that nature but the truth is
go to people who want it.
I would tell you don't
sell to the unsellable.
Like we don't need the clip here
and be like see Gary.
Like me saying come to live events,
if that's not the kind of way you learn...
Look, the reason to come
to a Gary Vee event is
to network with the other
fuckers in the place.
- [Nik] Amen.
- Like you're around other
people that are hungry
and trying to win and do shit.
Like yeah, there you go man.
Until like that's the ROI,
like after everybody pours out
and goes to the streets of Rochester
or whatever the fuck
you guys do around here.
You know, like go fucking do shit.
Like meet people, like
people are gonna hang around
and do stuff and like...
you know and then also
the cool thing about that
is like the Rolling
Stones and like Aerosmith
and like Billy Joel and The Beatles.
Like The Beatles
performed a trillion times
but there is the Shea Stadium event.
Like this could be the night
that like I do say the thing
that like my whole legacy is known for
and then if I get cool and big
one day, that's cool, right?
Like the reason to go to a concert is
like they may play a song a certain way
or somebody may come out
and jam with somebody
that they've never jammed
with before, right?
Like or Jerry Garcia will
just show up from the dead.
I don't know, like something will happen.
And I think that to me if I loved keynotes
and business or me the
reason I would come out is...
there was a time where I said
what's the ROI of your mother?
Or stop watching fucking Lost
and if you're a hardcore me fan
and you were there the time
it was dropped, that's cool.
The same way I would go
to a wrestling match.
I know Macho Man is gonna
beat George "Animal" Steele
every time but it might be the night
that he brings out his
new flying elbow version
and so what's cool about live
is you actually don't know.
- [Nik] That's why we've done--
- This could be the night
somebody comes to run up
and like sure like hates
me and I knock them out
with a right hook and it's amazing
and it's like, you know
like you just never know.
And I think that's why you go live.
- [Nik] He's so athletic.
- Yeah, what a jab.
- [Nik] No but that's kind
of like when Prince died.
Our icon, our lifeblood
here in the lands of 10K
when Prince died that weekend,
if you went and saw a live
music that weekend bro,
the purple rains will never be the same.
Like a Dave Matthews Band
over Super Bowl weekend,
just the homage they were
playing or I saw Dave--
- Do you love Dave Matthews?
- [Nik] I do, I do.
- Who's your favorite?
- [Nik] What do you mean?
- Period.
- [Nik] Artist, growing up?
- Rap, hiphop?
- No dude, I grew up on...
I love hip-hop but I grew
up on Eminem obviously
but I grew up on classic rock.
Dude it was Pink Floyd.
- I get it.
- But the weekend that Rick James died,
that was arguably one of
the best Dave Matthews
Band concerts to be at
because they played Super Freak
and they made it extra funky
and it's it's moments like
that where it's like--
- That's why live can always play
and even when it's not extra funky,
if you love fucking Dave
Matthews but not really
and let me explain what I mean by this.
If you love Dave Matthews in this version
which is you see Dave Matthews Band three
or four times in your life,
you want to hear Satellite.
You know 'cause you're a
fake Dave Matthews fan.
If you're a real Dave
Matthews fan, you want to see.
I'm not, my wife is ironically.
You want to hear some
other fucking real shit
like some nerd shit, right?
Same when I go out there right now.
There's gonna be fans.
Well there's not as many as Dave Matthews
but a hundred people
that are hardcore fans
that 80 of them are
hardcore quote-unquote,
they just want to hear me curse.
They just think that's awesome.
The ones that a really hardcore
like is he gonna go more into
the parenting thing tonight?
Is even go social media?
Like they know, they
know that like you know?
And so I think that's cool.
Like I went years spending
the first 10 minutes
of my keynote talking about
Russia, baseball cards,
lemonade stands, I don't do that anymore.
Not because I think I've made it
but I think enough of a
percentage of the audience
has heard it on YouTube that
I want to bring them value.
That's why I only want to do Q&A.
I just want, Q&A is amazing
'cause I'm given all sorts
of shit that I never give.
You put me in Q&A I can bring
up new content in perpetuity.
- [Nik] It wouldn't be a
Stationary Astronaut podcast Gary
if I didn't ask you this one question.
- How many episodes have
there been at the Stationary--
- You are episode 104.
- Good for you man, what
was that one episode one?
- Episode one was just me and
my two co-hosts at the time.
Episode--
- Who was the biggest
guess you had before me?
- [Nik] Oh shit.
I had James Arthur Ray, the
co-writer of The Secret.
Episode 99--
- What's he say about The Secret
'cause I think these secret scares,
I've never read it so I want to shit on it
but this notion of like
think it and it will happen
scares me because I think
some people think like
lay on this couch right here,
think it, it will happen.
- [Nik] It got culty, it got very culty.
- Does he admit to that or is he in--
- [Nik] Yeah he does.
'Cause he went through
some tribulation dawg.
- Did he?
- [Nik] Yeah, where he
was running a retreat
and a few people died under his watch.
- Right, right, in the heat there?
- [Nik] Yeah, in the heat, sweat lodge.
Yeah so we got---
- [Nik] Is that the dude that
got like beef with Oprah?
It was all weird or is that--
- Yeah dude, yep, yep.
Yeah it got crazy so I got
into that and I was hammering
and that was my first
ever phone call interview
on the podcast and it got crazy man.
So I was asking him will you
ever push sweat lodges again?
No, I can't do it, you know?
So it got weird.
- Why is the sweat lodge good?
- [Nik] It actually pushes
your neurotransmitters
in your brain and it pushes your--
- Yeah, you know what
the best part for me is
I failed everything in science.
Like I'll never do shit
like that only because
I don't even, I wouldn't know.
You know what I mean?
Like when I hear that I'm like
what's a neurotransmitters
like I'm out.
- [Nik] Have you ever taken a psychedelic?
- No.
I've never fucking smoked a cigarette.
- [Nik] Really?
- That's the best shit about me.
That for me that makes me and my family
and like dear friends laugh.
My college friends whose
entire four-year admission
was to get me to take one puff of a blunt
and couldn't pull it off.
When they see people leave
comments in my Youtubes
of like coke head, they
like sometimes screenshot
and they send it to me and they're like
this is such funny shit.
You're so fucking the worst,
we couldn't get you to fucking
take one hit of one blunt.
Fucking, if these people
knew that you do nothing.
Like you don't even drink Red Bull.
They're like they wouldn't
fucking believe any of us.
We just laugh about it.
- [Nik] Damn, so you're the real deal?
- No, I don't think I'm the real deal.
As a matter of fact
with Aubrey and Ferriss
and all these fuckers I'm
like I think they're right.
Like I think taking some
weird fucking like grassy root
like a banana peel from the fucking Amazon
and it sends you into another
dimension is like smart.
I just don't want to do it.
But I think it like I'm
very like into it actually.
Like theoretic, you know how
honestly I feel about that?
Steroids, I think people
should do steroids.
Like I actually like kind of logically,
now let me preface this
because it's all on the record.
I'm not educated at all
but there's something that
feels intuitively right to me
that like the 45 year old average male
may just want to take steroids.
I think that's a good idea.
I'm desperately hoping that
self awareness and self esteem
get mapped as a chemical
and everybody can just
inject the fuck out of it.
If we can inject the
fuck out of self-esteem
into every person on earth,
everything would be fine.
You wouldn't be mad at fucking anybody.
If you had full self-esteem,
you'd be mad at no one.
Nobody who's brown, nobody who's black,
nobody who's a woman,
nobody who's a white male,
nobody who's in Alabama, in New York, LA,
conservative, liberal.
Like we'd all be chill.
If everyone was like me, I love everybody.
Unless you're a dick then I hate you.
And that's what self esteem is
and that's the fucking drug.
Fuck a mushroom that makes
you want to have sex longer
like let's get some
self-esteem going here.
If I stick a self-esteem up your ass,
you'll dominate life.
(laughs)
I mean that's fucking what's up.
Like let's start talking
about self-esteem.
That's the fucking drug I'm on.
Like Ritalin, coke, crack,
like all this speed,
like what people think I'm on.
That doesn't do anything.
That's fucking short-term, I'm long-term.
You want long-term, it's
self esteem and empathy.
Be kind and like have compassion
and also fucking have
compassion for yourself
and know that you're a winner.
Like find your shit.
Like don't listen to the
people that shit on you.
Like get in your own head,
put positivity around you,
drop loser friends.
Like don't hang out with losers.
If your mom's a loser get
the fuck out of there.
If your buddy from around the way,
like I believe in loyalty the most.
I'm a fucking (spits)
guy more than anybody
but guess what if your
buddies a fucking loser
and just thinks the
government and society,
like you have to drop them.
You have to hang out
with them once a year,
not a every day and like let's
start having mental talk.
- [Nik] Boom and that's
what we're doing tonight.
Thank you for coming.
Gary, welcome to the Stationery Astronaut.
- Thank you my man, thanks for having me.
Ese.
- All right, ese baby,
you're going on stage
in literally two minutes.
- Well, I'm primed.
(electronic music)